joke laugh fox sports lead college
football analyst will join us coming up
here in a moment I'm gonna try to go the
entire interview and not ask him a
question but is that an interview if I
don't ask him a question it's a
conversation I'm not even gonna give him
a talk about here Michael in Iowa joins
us hey Mike what do you have for me
today hey Dan
five nine one sixty
so that's been talking about how you
don't talk about that's recent I ask a
question and you also touched on the
situation the Super Bowl where you
didn't get to ask Nick Foles about his
daughter yeah other things rested on not
give up the microphone yeah you heard
somebody if they want to grab her from
you yeah well in other situation calls
your talk to Jeffrey Lurie and he ended
up grabbing the microphone kind of force
it away from you and I was wondering how
you handle that situation different
Syria what kind of that situation well
I'm the wife of bangs you don't give up
the right well because I have an
allotted amount of time so that's why
and thanks for the phone call Michael so
if I give up the microphone then all of
a sudden you have and it's normally
owners who want to grab the microphone
because they don't get a chance it's
their moment and Jeffrey Lurie and
granted it's a great moment and he said
look prior to prior to the ceremony
starting and you know he said look I
have somebody I want to thank to just
make sure I get the time to do it and I
thought great and I asked him a couple
of questions I waited for him to thank
whoever he was going to thank and then
he grabbed the microphone so he
surprised me because I thought that he
had done what he wanted to do but I
don't want to rip it out of your hands
because he wanted to pay tribute to his
parents so he surprised me
I had Robert Kraft who tried to grab it
one of the Giants owners I you know
Steve Tisch he grabbed it now I have to
pull it without making it seem like
there's a tug of war on national TV and
with Robert Kraft and Steve Tisch I have
to let them know that they're not
getting the microphone because Robert
Kraft really wanted to he wanted the
moment but we only have a certain amount
of time and I got to get the owner
I'll get the quarterback if he's not the
MVP if he is the MVP then I might get
one or two other players and with the
Patriots I had Belichick I had Gronk I
had Brady and I believe Edelman might
have been up there as well it's just it
happened so quickly and I've only got a
couple of I got two questions
maybe three for the MVP two questions
and then throw it back upstairs and that
that surprised me but yes I have had the
tug of war with the microphone twice in
handing out the Super Bowl trophy joke
lat fox sports lead college football
analyst he's on the call with the Red
River Rivalry showdown between number 19
Texas number 2 Oklahoma that's on Fox at
noon Eastern coverage begins at 10 a.m.
Eastern with Fox Sports 1 to our edition
of Fox college football pregame from the
State Fair of Texas continuing at 11:00
a.m. Eastern on Fox Sports 1
and Fox alright Joel good morning let's
let's play finish that statement morning
all right you ready you were just
talking about trophy presentations
they're really nerve-wracking so I have
to do it at the big 10 not nearly the
level of Super Bowl but a quick story
that I think that you're gonna find
humorous
because you were talking about giving up
the microphone it's like the cardinal
sin of hosting the tree throw fee
presentation well last year I committed
even the worst said I I had them throw
me the broadcast on the stage before I
knew who the MVP was and so they said
hey are you ready yeah yeah yeah I'm
ready and then all of a sudden I guess
Joe and I don't have to talk back
communication with the producer and I'm
thinking to myself oh my gosh I have no
idea who the MVP is I'm trying to look
at the Jumbotrons to see like are they
putting it up early so I had to make the
executive decision that Jim Delany the
Commissioner of the Big Ten was he's
getting the mic because I got a dive
behind him and asked Archie Griffin who
do you see is who was given the trophy
for so I gave Jim the mic dive back I
asked Archie who the MVP is he says JK
Dobbin
I kind of grabbed him by the shoulders
and I looked at him in his panic mode
and I said Archie are you sure and he
looks at me shocked and he was like I
think so and so I said JK Dobbins with
like 56% belief that that was the MVP
but anyway I'm out here that was dude
we've shared that experience when the
Steelers beat Arizona in the Superbowl
and I thought Ben Roethlisberger was
going to be the MVP and he should have
been but we get to right before the
trophy presentation and I
I have to you know pay homage and talk
about the Super Bowl MVP I don't know
who it is nobody's told me who it is
there's chaos getting up on the podium
absolute chaos and I'm yelling and it's
so loud I said who is the MVP to whoever
will listen to me and I finally I
Roethlisberger comes up and I think Ben
thinks he's the MVP and then I see
Santonio Holmes I think he thinks he's
the MVP and so I'm yelling who is the
MVP I finally get this voice Holmes and
I go oh my god
and then the Commissioner comes up the
ceremony starts with Joe Namath bringing
the trophy up ongoing because it was
such an unbelievable finish and then
here I am going I don't know who the MVP
is so right I understand you know that
that pain that you were feeling alright
finish the sentence okay if Texas beats
Oklahoma danta they will be back we've
been talking about this forever right
for almost a decade we've been waiting
Texas to be back and and that's always
that the big deal but the bottom line is
after a decade of waiting and maybe even
wandering through the desert of football
there in Austin Texas there are 60
minutes away from being back and you
could say listen they've beaten Oklahoma
before in the last couple of years yes
but this is different this time they're
ranked this time they're on a four-game
winning streak this time they've beaten
TCU they've beaten us see that's two
ranked wins this season this time they
would be putting themselves squarely in
the conversation for the big 12 title
and then given the playoffs with the
resume that they're starting to build so
the Texas wins their back if Kentucky
beats a.m. oh gosh panic because then
you have the actual scenario in your
head that if they were to upset Georgia
Alabama would have to play Kentucky in
the SEC championship game and nobody
wants to see that nobody wants to see
Alabama hang
100 on Kentucky if Virginia Tech beats
Notre Dame or vice-versa
oh gosh I'll be shocked if [ __ ] the
tech beats Notre Dame this is a team
that gave up 60 points you know 600
yards is the Old Dominion you know so
I'll be shocked I think Notre Dame is a
bona fide playoff team yeah it just
feels like it's a tricky game it's it's
you know the quarterbacking situation it
seems like Notre Dame's found their
quarterback Virginia Tech lost their
quarterback but I don't know it's just
Notre Dame always has one of these games
it feels like every year you know almost
every team does when you really think
about it even Alabama has been immune to
one of being a quote/unquote one of
these games so I hear you and that's not
an easy place to play I will tell you
though that the the insertion of Ian's
book in the lineup has just changed my
whole outlook name because now all of a
sudden they're explosive offensively you
know in their first three games man they
score 70 total points in their last two
they scored 94 and that was again
against Stanford you know and I think
Stanford is still pretty good although
they might have been running out of gas
after two straight road games against
ranked opponent so I do think Notre Dame
is is serious and let me put it to you
this way I think this is an interesting
game to play out and I think maybe I'm
ahead of myself but let's say let's just
say for the sake of argument Notre Dame
and Clemson finished the season
undefeated it's gonna be so easy to say
Notre Dame has the better resume it
should be included in the playoff over
Clemson with the way the Clemson has
played and the weakness of their
schedule and the resume thus far Nick
Saban's newest opponent is the student
fanbase at Alabama crazy Dan when you're
this good but you've got a hunt for
Coach Joel he's Saban is the problem he
makes the game's boring because he's so
good he's the B's you know good but he's
the reason why these fans show up and
they're sort of
ever let's do a drive-by and then you
know let's let's go ahead to a party I
will say this it is hard to blame bands
because you've got to go back to the
1950s Oklahoma dynasty under bud
Wilkinson to have the level of dominance
that you're seeing right now from
Alabama that's you know that going back
to his second year that they have been
ranked number one at some point during
the season in every single year that's
insane
to me absolutely insane when you think
about the national recruiting bases that
several programs have when you think
about the 85 scholarships the amount of
parity driven by all the television
dollars given out generally as a rule
you know evenly across conferences in
particularly you know within the SEC I
think it's shocking what he's been able
to do so it's hard to blame the fans for
for what they do I do know this that the
Alabama student ticket like allotment is
in a lottery basis and it's in a
rotation so the students down there one
of our babysitter's actually just this
is a freshman at Alabama
so she was explaining all of this this
summer before she went to college she
was saying that you gotta apply in the
lottery and order tickets and then you
only get tickets to a couple of games
and one of the things that she was
saying is the students are all praying
that they don't get the
louisiana-lafayette and because no one
wants to go there you go there's their
invitations Nick Saban is mad at the
podium
give me another game to keep an eye on
this weekend I think LSU Florida is a
really good game because quite frankly I
think border has the potential to upset
LSU
I still think LSU is a bit overrated and
the reason is is they've just got no
consistency on offense they played well
offensively last week and boro had his
best game as a tiger there's no doubt
about it
but before that they had a hard time
playing offense out of a wet paper bag
let's be honest so I think that's an
interesting game because Florida as
they're getting better under Mullen has
a chance to maybe upset the Tigers have
a fun weekend there and the Red River
Rivalry the showdown it's always fun at
the state fair there and you
the game is Texas and Oklahoma starts at
noon Eastern on Fox go to visit with you
Joel thanks for joining us
I appreciate it dan at least I don't
have to do a trophy presentation I think
I made it through the entire interview
without asking a question yes you you
open your mic eight times and you never
asked a true question I'm not proud of
that though but that was the goal yeah
who have a conversation yeah you can
have a conversation with questions
finish the statement with guy no I know
finish the state dot dot dot yeah and I
almost caught myself asking a question
they're like no you can't let's see if
we can make it through the entire
interview with us without asking a
question for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]